breaking overnight president-elect joe
biden has announced a string of top
appointees who could dramatically change
the government's response
to the coronavirus pandemic nicole
killian is covering the transition she's
in wilmington delaware with more on this
story
nicole good morning to you who was on
the biden's team of health advisors
well gail there are several notable
picks here including the
president-elect's choice to lead the
department of health
and human services california attorney
general javier basira as hhs secretary
becerra would oversee the coronavirus
response
and a budget totaling more than a
trillion dollars if confirmed he would
be the first latino to fill the role
becerra doesn't have a public health
background but has been a staunch
defender
of the affordable care act and prior to
his time as california's top lawyer he
helped shepherd it through the house as
a congressman
mr biden revealed his choice to lead the
cdc as well dr richelle wilinski
a harvard medical school professor and
the chief of infectious diseases
at massachusetts general hospital the
president-elect selected dr vivek murthy
to reprise his former role as u.s
surgeon general he's already on biden's
covid advisory board and of course dr
anthony fauci
will serve as the president-elect's
chief medical advisor now cbs news has
also exclusively learned that the
president-elect is announcing new
co-chairs for his
presidential inaugural committee this
morning it will be led
by house majority with jim clyburn along
with
two other congressional members michigan
governor gretchen whitmer
and los angeles mayor eric garcetti tony
all right nicole thank you very much the